Cheeta is a character and injustice to
great who the hell is that besides
someone that stole spider-man's finisher
from Marvel vs. Capcom before we get
into that I want to tell you guys about
universe GameSpot's channel for
everything else we love other than games
the channels called GameSpot universe
check it out in the description below or
click the button right here now I'll
tell you why it really doesn't make
sense that she too hates Wonder Woman I
long for Amazon a lot and how she became
half cat
the character backstory for cheetah on
the injustice 2 website is when
archaeologist Barbara and Minerva
betrayed Wonder Woman to claim the
powers of a god she was unaware that she
would be cursed to live a life
transformed as the cheetah she now uses
her primal powers to take revenge
against Wonder Woman drawing her out of
hiding in hopes of bringing about her
doom this might be perfect for in-game
lore but it doesn't fit neatly into any
of the 4 cheetah backstories that have
existed throughout DC history because
cheetah wasn't transformed because of
her betraying Wonder Woman injustice 2
focuses specifically on the 3rd cheetah
and in the comics there are a few
different backstories for that specific
cheetah Barbara is an archaeologist and
heiress to an ancient family estate
called Nottinghamshire her father was a
big jerk which probably doesn't help
while on an expedition in Africa she
witnesses a ritual to invigorate an old
woman as the cheetah skin wearing avatar
of the plant God hers cart again as
cardigan or something
the woman is shot before the right can
be completed and Barbara demands to take
her place after hearing she can gain
immortality and power the ceremony
requires a blood sacrifice so Barbara
just kills her friend drinks his blood
and becomes the cheetah
she takes chumma the tiny old priest who
performed the ritual back to England
with her to be her manservant there's a
problem though the ritual is technically
a marriage to the goddess cardigan and
he only weds virgins
so Barbara being a worldly
globe-trotting archaeologist is cursed
with extreme weakness and pain in her
human form to the point that she must
walk with a cane and during full moons
she turns into a cheetah and hungers for
human blood like a werewolf only with a
cat to wear cat none of that is Wonder
woman's fault though so why does she
hate Wonder Woman as far as I can tell
the archaeologists side of cheetah
wanted to steal the lasso of truth from
Diana because of its historical value
she does so and in the ensuing pursuit
chuma the priests team and servant is
killed and cheetah is put into jail you
could hate someone for killing
manservant right hold on just one second
wall in jail
she'd has given a potion that turns her
into a cat full time and she escapes
returning to the jungle to serve as
cardigan as a psycho man killing cheetah
lady
Wonder Woman then goes to the jungle and
frees her from her curse and tells her
that her marriage was really abusive and
that she cares about her cheetah agrees
and they hug and cry while in cheetah
form Barbara has superhuman strength
durability speed and agility to the
point that she can trade blows with
Wonder Woman she has cat-like senses
claws and fangs so what should you
expect when you play as cheetah and
injustice to cheetahs listed as a b-tier
who utilizes grabs and jumping attacks
to deal damage she may not have the
greatest range as she'll need to be up
close for her normal attacks to reach
but she makes up for it with speed and
some nasty mix ups her character power
the claws of death just adds extra
damage to any attacks that involve her
claws which is basically almost every
move she has if you're looking for
someone who can quickly and easily close
the distance on your opponent and offer
some quick overhead attacks along the
way cheetah might just be perfect for
you
[Music]
hey guys did you guys like that cool cuz
universe has all kinds of content like
that we cover anime TV shows movies
right now we have an anime piece about
boobs you like boobs of course you do I
got a cat scratch on my hand
right now it's from a real cat not from
cheetah anyway more weird like this over
on universe